[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompañan doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor gracias por
esta comunicación y por su compañía
empezamos con el repunte de los
contagios en europa en plena segunda ola
porque países como la república checa a
la cabeza en número de casos positivos
se están rompiendo récords después de
meses de pandemia con cifras
relativamente bajas
si alan lo que sucedió en un república
checa y en esta parte de europa es que
fue muy fuerte el inicio en cuanto al
confinamiento al distanciamiento pero
con el pasar del tiempo después de 67
meses que la gente no empezó a cumplir
las normas y lo que estamos viendo
críticas es en la república checa
prácticamente una primera ola con un
incremento muy acelerado del caso de eso
que nos indica que si se pierden las
medidas de higiene de distanciamiento
físico en algún momento pues regresen
los dos
el comportamiento viral no cambia sino
el comportamiento humano cambia y eso
incrementa el número de casos además de
que se pierdan estas medidas de higiene
a que más se debe el repunte de
contagios en estos países
recordemos que los rebrotes no dependen
del comportamiento viral es decir los
vídeos no dicen cada dos meses vamos a
aparecer nuevos casos es el
comportamiento humano el virus está ahí
no se ha ido está presente y si nosotros
interactuamos y lo acercamos a nuestros
hogares los llevamos a nuestros trabajos
pues se van a incrementar el número de
casos es decir que lo rebrote no
dependen del comportamiento viral en
ninguna parte del mundo dependen de
nuestro comportamiento como humanos como
puede afectar la segunda ola de
contagios a los países que han tenido
controlada la pandemia durante estos
siete meses y que no tienen esa llamada
inmunidad de rebaño en su población
podría ser el caso de uruguay no
hablando de américa latina'
la inmunidad de rebaño alan es una
inmunidad que en los virus respiratorios
no se ha visto desde el principio de la
pandemia lo hemos hablado se necesita
que cerca de un 70 por ciento de las
personas 80% las personas estuvieran
contagiados en los estudios de la de
meses significan que solamente el 10 por
ciento de la población mundial está
tiene inmunidad relativa contra el virus
y en américa latina no es la excepción y
qué significa esto que nosotros mientras
seamos susceptibles podemos hacer
rebrote en este momento cerca del 80 o
90 por ciento de las personas en américa
latina siguen siendo susceptibles y por
eso pago es la posibilidad de rebrotes
depende de nuestro comportamiento
hablado más de estos países con pocos
casos previamente cómo se comporta el
virus en estas poblaciones donde no ha
habido un contagio masivo previo y por
lo tanto la inmunidad es menor
definitivamente pues hay más
susceptibilidad de las personas y
recuerden que las medidas de
confinamiento no eliminan el virus
simplemente desacelera en la replicación
vida en la producción de nuevos casos es
decir que por más que estemos encerrados
no va el virus no se va a desaparecer de
un país de una ciudad de un pueblo es
una medida transitoria entonces en la
medida que se relajan extrañas de
confinamiento y si se cumple el
distanciamiento físico disminuirá el
número de casos pero si no se usan los
tapabocas aumentará el número de casos
que lo que estamos viendo actualmente en
europa los vulnerables son los mismos
cuáles son los sectores poblacionales de
mayor riesgo en esta segunda ola con las
aperturas en marcha al inicio de la
pandemia lo afectaba principalmente a
mayores adultos adultos mayores perdón y
personas con alguna enfermedad
diagnóstica
claro es que al principio eran las
personas mayores y con mayores como la
idea de las que más fallecieron que
estamos bien en esta segunda ola que son
personas más jóvenes las personas
trabajadoras las personas que están
yendo a la playa y que tienen como
habilidades que se están afectando hemos
visto dos cosas son más jóvenes y llegan
menos casos para cuidado intensivo pero
los casos que llegan acontecido llegan
muy graves porque porque se automedican
porque consultan tarde y porque no
tienen un acceso a sistemas de salud en
algunas partes del mundo de una forma
fácil por eso el llamado es a reactivar
nos con optimismo con decisión pero con
cuidado con un alejamiento físico con
uso de cubrebocas y seguir las
instrucciones oficiales
doctor y para finalizar nos quedan sólo
unos segundos la segunda ola podría ser
peor que la primera
eso depende en nuestro comportamiento el
número de casos se puede incrementar
pero definitivamente los pacientes
críticos y la mortalidad no va a ser tan
importante como la primera hora ahora
conocemos más
sabemos cómo enfrentarlo pero depende de
nosotros no depende del ictus muy bien
doctor carlos eduardo pérez muchas
gracias al médico infectólogo del
universidad nacional de colombia por sus
consejos y ustedes por su compañía ya lo
sabe siga con más mucho más en france 24
[Música]